COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE BE
ADVISED ON AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDING IS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IS ALSO
BEING TESTED TELEVISED MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM SENATE.
FLORA GIVES HERE LI LEVINE MAIN.
MATHIS THERE RAMOS RUBIO. THE
FOOD WHAT YEAR WE REQUIRE. WE
HAVE QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENTED.
MOVERS WRAP THIS FROM GIBBS OR
MRS SIR APPROVED THE ROLL
COOLEY HI JULIE I CAN BENNETT.
BENNETT HI FLORA GIPSON HI
GIPSON LEAVE LIVING MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
RAMOS RUBIO. RUBIO HIGH
APPROVED. PEOPLE WHO ARE HIGH
MOTION PASSES MOTIONS CRASH AND
THIS RULES IS A- THANK YOU SIR.